r vous pas vraiment à la rue mais je
réserve de 26 pas rien je reste
complètement libre au total au métier
dit que ici tout le monde est engagé moi
je m'engage je suis allé j'ai connu
quand il ya deux ans que je travaille
dans les journaux libres via les
journaux libres et si on pourra
reprocher signé pendant la prochaine
année 66 j'ai rien fait je suis tenu à
l'écart je crois que j'ai peut-être
dépendance vaguement très vaguement de
gaulle ce que je crois à l'ascension
d'un premier mariage crois que les gens
un jour se mettront même à ne plus
prouvé de faim dans le monde et aviv
bien ici d'ailleurs mais c'est tout à
fait sûrs et égoïste de ma part je me
dis plus il ya moins de chômeurs et si
les gens ont un peu plus d'argent ils
achètent en 14-18 non vous auriez pas
participé à ce mouvement des
dessinateurs qui font des choses
absolument épouvantable pour donner pour
dire pardon pour français que les ceux
d'en face ont d'évidence épouvanté
facile de ma part de dire non maintenant
mais là parce que j'ai pu faire
maintenant j'ai envie de savourer un
léger comme ça rien ne vais pas d'arêtes
jerry à l'époque je suis un précisé
mêmes galtier bois soeur et même le
canard enchaîné qui né en 1916 quand
même ils pouvaient vendre des
chaussettes et ne pas énoncer des allées
alors été décidée ils ont aussi une
guerre épouvantable arrive maintenant
j'en ai décidé
même si par exemple vous pensez que
votre pays est en danger et que vos
dessins pourrait donner du moral aux
civils
cabanas disait toute façon que quand une
bière était commencé toute façon c'est
trop tard une fois que la guerre est
incroyable tout ce qui nous met
pratiquement plus rien faire quoi les
urnes ont d'avancé maintenant